[Musique]
chaque jour Sharifa passe plusieurs
heures à aider sa petite sœur à faire
ses devoirs elle cache sa blessure à
l'oreille gauche sous son voile était sa
douleur
chalifa est une rescapée de la tentation
éducatif le 30 septembre dernier et
fortement voici mes amis Fatima est
morte Sabina a été blessée et là c'est
moi quand nous avons pris cette photo
nous pensions qu'une fois nos examens
d'entrée à l'université terminée nous ne
pourrions plus nous voir nous avons pris
cette photo comme un souvenir mais
maintenant je ne peux plus regarder ces
photos ça me brise le coeur
Sharifa et ses camarades passaient leur
examen lorsqu'un kamikaze a fait
éruption dans leur salle de classe
l'examen avait commencé j'avais répondu
à une dizaine de questions quand soudain
des coups de feu je me suis caché sous
la table je ne me souviens pas de ce qui
s'est passé ensuite quand je suis revenu
à moi tout était en feu le mur de la
classe était effondré et tout le monde
courait partout
ces vidéos amateurs diffusées sur les
réseaux sociaux montrent la violence de
l'explosion à l'extérieur de
l'établissement des parents effondrés la
plupart des victimes sont des filles
toutes Azara la minorité chie est en
Afghanistan majoritaire a acheté barthy
un quartier de l'ouest de Kaboul
c'est là que le lendemain de la date des
dizaines d'afghane ont manifesté contre
les violences qui vise la minorité
chiite une manifestation dispersée par
les talibans qui tiraient en l'air
[Musique]
zarel une des manifestantes elles seront
ce jour-là sur la tombe de l'une des
victimes Maria
[Musique]
est un esprit libre qui rêvait de
pouvoir se promener paisiblement la nuit
dans les rues marcher paisiblement dans
la rue est un souhait très simple mais
aucun de ses rêves n'a pu se réaliser
[Musique]
d'une attaque suicide en 2018 elle
refuse de se taire yakmas
nous avons une responsabilité il y a 4
ans j'ai perdu mes amis dans une attaque
similaire et cette année encore nous
avons perdu les étudiants comme Marcia
peut-être que ces manifestations
n'auront pas d'impact peut-être qu'elle
n'arrêteront pas le génocide des hasards
mais c'est mieux d'élever sa voix au
lieu de rester silencieux et de tolérer
l'inacceptable
dans le quartier Azara ce centre
éducatif a déclaré forfait après
l'attaque du 30 septembre dernier les
responsables ont décidé de mettre la clé
sous la porte
il y avait deux classes ici des
centaines d'étudiants qui sont passés
dans ces classes ont été acceptées dans
différentes universités d'Afghanistan à
cause des problèmes de sécurité nous
sommes contraints de fermer cette
institution et de détruire toutes les
salles de classe 10 jours auparavant cet
endroit ressemblait à ceci c'est une
photo prise par l'un des étudiants de
cette classe mais aujourd'hui tout est
en ruine
accueillait 800 élèves mais aucun
dispositif de sécurité n'a jamais été
mise en place par les nouvelles
autorités talibanes malgré les menaces
sécuritaires
en Afghanistan nous n'avons pas de
pouvoir nous n'avons pas d'armes nous
n'avons aucune autre ressource le seul
moyen de nous en sortir et la
connaissance si la situation continue
comme ça nous retournerons 100 ans en
arrière
la population chiite discriminée en
Afghanistan et souvent visé dans des
attaques du groupe état islamique depuis
2015 l'une de leurs cibles ces mini
Vannes qui servent de transport
collectif
Azim est devenu particulièrement
vigilant
l'année dernière un véhicule juste
devant moi sur la route a exploser
dieu merci je n'ai pas été blessé j'ai
eu très peur
nous les chauffeurs de minivan nous
n'avons pas beaucoup de travail mais
nous faisons attention à ne pas prendre
des personnes suspectes
nous ne le laissons pas seul
il y a toujours un garde qui veille
dessus
ce passager est aussi tendu
je suis stressé j'ai peur qu'il y ait
une explosion ou qu'un kamikaze se fasse
exploser dans ce quartier il y a plus
d'attaques ailleurs donc on a toujours
peur ici
[Musique]
sont engagés à protéger les minorités
ils ont échoué jusqu'à ce jour tout
comme l'ancien régime avoue avant eux